aussi je suis heureuse de soumettre
aujourd'hui à la représentation
nationale un projet de loi d'orientation
et d'incitation à la réduction de la
durée du travail en introduisant devant
vous cet après midi les 35 heures
prince et kurdy mission au baba c'est
quoi ton histoire outils refus ya que
toi pour faire ça cyril battait tout
mais on veut par tous
sauf à bitlis en kata s'endormir bricout
travaux alors que là ça va être
compliqué mais je sais qu'il va gérer
parce que c'est pour le meilleur
le meilleur animateur du paris salle
dumont si je suis de tout coeur avec toi
je te fais des gros gros gros gros gros
gros gros bisous courage courage courage
on y croit on y croise chercher je te
souhaite bonne chance pour des 35 heures
il n'oublie pas de biais et hydrate et
c'est très important et pense aussi à
des fruits parce qu'elle débite ami si
tu as besoin d'un coach pour bien bouger
20 35 heures
cyril c'est joyce j'ai hâte de suivre
son record mondial je te souhaite bonne
chance
c'est long 35 heures courage les amiens
bravo pour ce que vous faites vous
envoie toute ma force je suis de tout
coeur avec vous un grand malade de faire
35 heures d'émissions en tout cas
j'espère qu'il va battre le record
je souhaite bon courage à tous être
l'équipe fait plein de maisons après cet
été
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vim
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rihaoui
et
[Applaudissements]
avec tous les chéris on va faire
je vais vous expliquer un petit peu
parce qu'il a passé à l'échec pour
l'instant on a démarré sur ce plateau ça
va être une émission confession je vous
dis tout de suite ça va être énorme je
vais être un petit peu le sophie davant
de ses huit voix la base de toute une
histoire et je suis une cougar esquif
les mecs et j'ai pas dis à ma meuf qui
était sorti avec son meilleur ami des
doses comme ça que j'adore pour
m'accompagner
j'ai appris voilà mais valérie bénaïm
qui s'est tenue il ya notre psychologue
toujours à l'antenne
et notre voyant vous allez voir donc ça
c'est pour la suite je vous le dis il y
aura camille et baba camier baba alors
je le dis comme ça se passait deux
équipes et on va s'affronter sur plein
d'épreuves
ensuite il y aura touche pas à mon poste
normal ensuite il y aura c'est pour nous
c'est cadeau ensuite il y aura des
missions et des records tous les
chroniqueurs de touche pas à mon poste
on bat des records fous les chéris vous
allez voir ensuite je serai là pendant
la nuit pour prendre beaucoup de fils je
serai avec jean michel mr et caroline
ithurbide où elle a pris les deux plus
chaud de l'équipe 1 voilà pour vous
accompagner
et donc voilà et vous pourrez nous
appeler ne pas nous appeler et voilà
nous donner des problèmes on fera des
jeux où vous allez voir des actions
vérité enfin tout ce que vous aimez bien
soprano qui viendra nous voir bien sûr
dans touche pas à mon poste il ya ayem
aussi qui viendra nous voir dans touche
pas à mon poste et on aura une surprise
- la compagnie robidas on va démarrer
paris première mission c'est parti
[Musique]
et
c'est
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être avec nous on est en direct
donc sur ces vitesses j'ai retrouvé ce
plateau sans rigoler ça fait longtemps
qu'on n'était pas là mais elle est
excusez moi
alors excusez moi que vous vous êtes vos
jours pascal ça va marcher kalou et
pascal pitch c'est lui qui a créé la
brioche donc on va faire un record avec
moi pascal parce que pendant les 35
heures il va pédaler pendant trente cinq
heures pendant tout mon record frérot
juste moi je suis hyper content que tu
sois la justesse que je peux tu peux pas
les pédales et la batterie loin sans m'a
dit j'ai l'impression déjà que je suis
arrivé je n'osais pas quand vous êtes
dans un [ __ ] tels gens vraiment un
hôtel vraiment ripoux maï maï maï m'est
arrivé d'abord les hôtels ripoux genre
dans des pays voilà ouf et et vous
entendez en fait le truc qui tourne
toute la nuit on dirait qu'il ya un gars
qui va chercher des moustiques sera tête
de ma mère
servat mas 4 pascal si on m'a dit non
j'adore mais y'a et on ne peut pas vous
mentir et pas mokhtar pour le porter
jusqu'à là bas monsieur n'ont pas de
portée
pascalou va c'est vrai vous pouvez pas
le pouvait pas non non non non tout
autant de noms mais non mais attends je
vais ce territoire bien commencé avec
toi avait dit je le fais avec toi allez
vas-y tu es pas encore cramé on va le
faire
entre à des petits chalets retour et
merci partiale et pascal je rappelle que
on donnera demi au à l'association c'est
que du bonheur dès qu'on passera une
heure d'antenne donc 35 heures
normalement 35000 euros
mais j'espère que la voix va tenir dial
docteur qui va arriver à 14h15 je vous
le dis tout de suite va bien les
analyses ne s'est pas fait mais voilà
peut-être et je veux bien faire les
analyses d'urines avec vous les révéler
si vous voulez mais voilà je vais faire
tout les annabis et benhaim est avec
nous cette audition alors j'ai ouvert
valérie est là parce que tous les deux
c'est nôtres qui fâchent ou pascal tu
peux pas les faire cuire seulement
pascal c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
pascal ta d'amour je rigole pascal reste
là c'était pour l'avs admettant que tu
me fais tu y fais à fond on s'habitue
aux moyens je vais te dire moi je
dormais avec un mec qui ronflait eux
donc voilà donc je te le dis ça vous
rappelle pas patoche ben maintenant vous
me le dites je me disais c'est un k-way
voilà mais si ça non mais c'était notre
kiffa valérie et moi de faire une
émission de témoignages
donc on est hyper content voilà de vous
retrouver aujourd'hui et je voulais
valérie avec moi absolument valérie vous
alles est un petit peu la grande soeur à
celle qui va donner des conseils et et à
côté de vous ayez un garçon que j'adore
ça fait longtemps vous vouliez de la
grande soeur williams est généralement
fait comme ça que les bains vous ce
qu'est le grand frère tu que pascal le
grand frère william carnimolla
riham l'expérience scénique messianistes
fashion spécialiste mode de vie comme au
travail lifestyle ça dans mon cas ça va
très bien déroulée au niveau du style
lui
ouais normal elle est sans lui on dirait
johnny en concert phare tiens si on m'a
mis j'aime bien celle là elle est
fraîche ah ouais t'es beau alors toi tu
vas donner des conseils aujourd'hui ok
tu va relooker des gens c'est ça
d'accord 1 mo williams était content
d'être avec nous oui je serai content
d'être là également il ya kaoutar
rousselet qui sera nos psychologues
sexologues kaluta remercions
alors il a six colloques sexologue ça
veut dire que vous n'avez aucun problème
de deux sexes sexologue est sexologue
ouais mais c'est à dire les gens
viennent vous voir tes oui on a du mal à
voilà et vous voilà ben oui en gros
c'est ça notre gilles verdez donne pas
encore d'accord est-ce que vous allez
croiser là les chéris je pense que même
pas pascal tu veux partir mais mettez le
lot on fera des points et pascal les
gars parce que là le saas et les idées
du gauche merci aux ordinateurs qu'on
embrasse d'un quart en tout cas merci
d'être là avoue deuil comme ça qui à
votre avis la de ce côté là a le plus de
problème de sexe comme ça à vue d'oeil à
partir et la vue d'oeil
non je peux dire celui qui en a pas tenu
compte dans les bras c'est qui ouais
c'est qui beinheim ouais c'est normal la
cervélo
ça fait capables ou non mais attendez
banide ont lâché prise je suis épanoui
dans le lâcher prise mais sans lâcher
prise aux risques fait se dresser sur
toile épanouie quand elle met les doigts
dans la prise et bien avec nous
notre voyant claude alexis comment ça va
claude très bien merci
je viens
allez c'est bon non pas
alors vous vous lisez dans les cartes de
la voyance directe à et je me sers de
mon chipant de cartes wade vient c'est
moi vous avez mangé le dernier
[Applaudissements]
premier en face du gard sont un
centenaire également mais j'ai entendu à
la fin que la fois des wii donc renoncer
pas le micro un non merde pas avec ça
que je le vois touché son micro c'est
pas le micro c'est c'est à sète à
personne qu'on aime comme ça tu
apprécies comme ça oui eux claude oui
alors donc tu peux tout donc wayan et je
me sers de mes cartes
[Rires]
alors est ce qu'on va faire un petit
exercice tient bon goût aussi d'ailleurs
regarder un petit exercice sur les 35
heures pour voir comment ça va se passer
je peux tirer des cartes
bien sûr je vais tirer des cas mais
comme les autres comme à monaco 2-2 car
cette à cette carte a quand même on est
on va le faire les 35 heures sur cette
séquence ion d'accord en fait ça va être
ça ça va être
alors où la la séparation ça m'arrange
pas ça veut rien dire le jeu je dise
qu'il ya un clodo pas du tout temps a
rien à [ __ ]
d'accord le changement je lis que nuit
la petite chute
une petite route petites routes écoutent
oui bon on peut craindre
oui je permettrai pas la sentais très
bien la femme âgée à parle de vous et
enfin la victoire aux dogues
on voit qu'on a un public de sophie
davant d'habitude la prévenue les gars
sont bâle sur rien du tout après j'ai
tiré cette carte on dirait que j'ai fait
un exploit mondial quoi alors qu'on dit
moi comment ça va se passer je la dis
moi dis moi la vérité ainsi je dois
apprendre des choses
si je dois me séparer des gens de mon
équipe par exemple et n'hésite pas à me
le dire
les imams le lien au niveau de ses 35
heures ça se passe merveilleusement bien
la seule chose elle seule chose ainsi
que toutes les émissions seront décalées
décalé web avec moi c'est sous des
cadets et ça prend plus de temps que ça
doit faire 40 heures maintenant vous
dépasser les 35 ans vraiment servent à
le dépasser
vous avez dépassé les 35 ans devrait
faire au moins une heure de plus
ouais si je suis pas payé sûr on peut
voir avec la production d'accord avec
l'eau du bain merci mais il a d'autres
choses à dire sinon succès en privé non
y'a pas privé claude non qu'est-ce
qu'elle ira dos taillez-les en angoisse
makwaia un délire santé ça va la santé
et / ou pas nantes est sensé sur l'amour
parce que j'étais ici qu'est ce que je
suis un petit picotement ici tous les
soirs quoi sur l'amour sur l'amour cyril
quoique essien
non mais tu peux dire après si c'est des
conneries je te dirai non mais dis moi
je suis là pour ça dis-moi héritage
préjugés pam on n'a pas compris à
ohlungen l'enfant bon enfant un enfant
vingt deux mois
[Rires]
ce qui s'est dit à betty surtout non ça
commence à savoir de quoi est un enfant
ouais mais qui met mais moi j'étais là
j'ai un enfant qui va arriver passé cinq
anciennes enfin qu'il va réfléchir qui
va arriver chez moi et ça tape à la
porte quand il veut des bonbons c'est
pas le mieux c'est vous qui le faites
pas c'est moi le père non mais il est
déjà en cours quoi l'enfant est en cours
quand on démarre très mal ces trois
structures comme hier quand même merci à
temps plein peut dire toi l'occident
voir pour vous témoigner beaucoup de
témoignages aujourd'hui et on à nicole
qui nous a rejoints nicole merci d'être
là merci à vous êtes magnifique nicole
merci je peux dire votre âge parce que
voilà ça fait partie de votre père de
notre personnalité et de votre
particularité vous avez 57 ans fait ça
et nicole et miss cougar
ça veut dire quoi déjà miss cougar c'est
quoi vous avez été élu en 2012 miss
cougar se dire vous êtes la plus belle
des cougars allez je vais dire la plus
belle des cougars aller ça n'est pas
vrai pas du tout cette fois il pas
d'abord pour les lecteurs qui savent pas
ce que c'est et cougar c'est quoi alors
une cougar c'est d'abord une femme
célibataire qui a au moins 40 ans oui
qui est arrivé valérie et liva terre bon
après on peut voir on peut voir qui est
donc épanouie qui est bien dans sa vie
et qui est qui qui aime sortir avec des
garçons plus jeunes et qui aime plutôt
plutôt peut bien sûr sortir fréquenté
avoir des relations avec des hommes bons
coups puis j'ai beaucoup bougé alors
est-ce que vous avez été mariée vous
avec un mec de votre âge ou pas du tout
où jamais mariée à 6 ici avec 1h plus
âgée avec un âge avec un homme plus âgé
il était avec moins de plus tôt on avait
7 à 7 en demi finale il avait divorcé
oui parce que quoi vous voulez mais je
sais qu'après moi un moment donné ouais
ça se renouvelle quoi ça qu'ils passent
aux stands
merci le château mais bon après une fois
qu'effectivement on connaît bien la
personne non mais c'est pas pour ça
à la suite de cette rupture vous êtes
dit que vous aimiez les plus jeunes ne
sais pas du tout non pas du tout pas du
tout c'est venu vraiment tout à fait
naturellement
ah ouais c'est venu naturellement c'est
quoi alors vous par exemple
voilà c'est quoi la limite d'âge pour
pour vous c'est bien la limite d'âge
alors le minimum ou maximum le maximum
ce serait aller à les 40 45 ans 40 35
ans - et elle rit moins que vous ayez
fait le plus jeune que avec qui j'ai une
belle histoire
enfin en vente au oui non ou méconnus ou
celui-là
allez corti voilà dans le nombre oui
celle en discothèque je vais dans des
soirées jeux
voilà des rencontres comme ça un petit
peu par la magie voilà une question
jones et surtout c'est le sait c'est
quoi c'est c'est quoi ces deux rapports
sexuels avec lui c'est quoi alors il ya
c'est un tout et c'est un tout bien
évidemment il ya évidemment le côté sexe
bien évidemment c'est pas que ça c'est
sûr que saab est nimbé non non non non
non y'a vraiment être tous et une
rencontre est une magie d'une rencontre
d'un regard de de quelque chose qui
passe qui passe bien bien évidemment ça
sera oui mais les rires je m'interroge
parce que souvent on a besoin d'avoir
des références en commun avec quelqu'un
qui à 20 ans de moins parfois on n'a pas
la même la même assez sur la même
référence justin bieber vous aimez dans
les bars
non pas du tout non c'est pas 20 h au
gros navet commune
[Rires]
et aujourd'hui vous êtes célibataire je
suis célibataire
alors c'est quoi ouais vous cherchez
l'amour ou chercher des aventures ou
alors ne c'est vrai que pour le moment
je cherche pas moi j'aime bien la magie
des moments donc ça peut-être sur un
plateau ce qui pourrait vous séduire
peut-être qui ça mais je regarde de
nulle part après faut voilà faut que les
voilà on élève alors chacun peut essayer
et on verra c'est autre chose sur
williams alors william est très charmant
mais fais pas mon style ah d'accord
bon la fringue mais pour demain c'est
vrai c'est quoi votre style de mec
méditerranéen
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous êtes très jolie en tout cas je vous
le dire ah non mais franchement mois
nicole vous êtes ma came je vous le dis
a fait bon écouter un quoi ces écoutes
et stérile
il parlait d'un enfant nicole alors
aujourd'hui donc vous êtes célibataire
qu'est ce que moi j'ai envie de savoir
parce que valérie vous ça vous viendrez
pas l'idée par exemple de sortir avec un
mec de 20 ans et non mais moi j ai déjà
dit j'aime les vieux donc enfin de
pourquoi parce que mais j'aime j'aime
bien l'idée d'être avec un la figure
masculine dont j'ai le sentiment qu'elle
puisse me protéger donc le côté un peu
plus âgés que moi j'ai le sentiment
qu'il va être plus enveloppants plus
paternel plus vite et trois touchés en
revanche du coup effectivement avec un
petit jeune je rêvais d'être moi la
patronne mois la protectrice mois la
voile a été clair et je sais ce que vous
avez fait que ta patronne a pas du tout
non non non mais je trouve que moi c'est
rien il ya vraiment un cocktail de des
choses dont je ne trouve pas que cela me
la patronne me c'est le qui domine ou
quoi j'ai en moi il faut que ce soit
vraiment quelque chose de beaucoup voir
quelque chose de joli quelque chose de
beau quelque chose de deux très
sensuelle en même temps les deux
ensemble à la communion est ce que vous
avez un enfant
nous avons mis et que leur gala à 37 ans
ouais mais comment ils le
alors il est vrai il est vrai que lors
de mon élection il n'a pas forcément
adhérer
je suis une maman vous lui présentez vos
mecs ou pas du tout à votre fils pas du
tout pas du tout non il ya la famille
wyss et salades à yala familiale il ya
ma vie privée et sexuelle et de votre
jambe bien mon il ya le côté maman je
suis ray mère poule de toute façon donc
j'aimerais mère poulard scheer et dit
quoi elle est par exemple vous parce
qu'on va vous présenter trois mecs je
vous le dis qu'ils mettent dans des
mascottes d'accord vous ne pouvez pas
des voix aurait pas des voix et on va
faire un jeu dans un instant mais juste
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des
histoires vraiment d'amour avec des mecs
beaucoup plus jeunes ou est ce que c'est
juste des aventures d'un soir
voilà ça se passait ce que vous avez eu
des aventures un peu longue avec des
gens plus âgés
alors j'ai eu évidemment comme on dit
des one shot mais des histoires longues
aussi avec bruit plus jeunes oui j'irai
pas vingt ans parce que ça ça peut être
vraiment l'histoire d'une petite soirée
et maintenant mais le plus que j'ai fait
ces 10 km
oui mais parce qu'une femme cougar c'est
aussi là l'amour fait lors mantis mais
ça peut être aussi comme je disais bon
air one shot mais ça peut être aussi un
one shot vous appeler ça comme ça ça
peut être aussi une histoire de plus
d'un mois peut-être parce qu'après
évidemment on respecte certaines choses
on n'est pas forcément liés pour la vie
mais en tout cas c'est vrai que c'est
une liberté au moins d'amour une liberté
sexuelle qui fait que si vous êtes resté
dix ans avec le jaune au bout de 10 ans
et la vie donc vous l'avez dégagée par
ce qu'il a exactement à certains noms
mais c'est vrai en fait dès qu'il ya un
mec qui trouve oui mais après
l'excellent et je fais blanc qui
commence
est ce que il est plus musclé dès qu'il
est plus sportif
moi j'aime bien les sportifs j'aime bien
les gens musclé j'aime bien les gens
rigolo on appelle à lui eu ma chance et
c'est pas parce qu'il avait pris 10 ans
qui sont notés ce que ce qui n'en est
plus chez lui et intellectuellement
avait changé bah un petit peu
physiquement et puis un petit peu aussi
dans moralement et puis un petit peu
dans la vie pépère
j'aime pas m'installer moi je suis
quelqu'un de très pétillante et de
positif je fais du sport je fais plein
de choses la danse chant je file diotte
parce que j'ai aussi j'adore l'humour
donc moi c'est xavier le mot vous avez
vu valérie elle est connue pour sa voix
l'a donc forcément ma j'ai besoin de ce
que vous avez un fantasme voilà
quelqu'un voilà qui est connue qu'on
connaît tous vrai vous avez dans la tête
voilà vous avez un fantasme dans le sang
et d'oxygène franche t'aimera qui donne
vraiment voilà vraiment petit chat non
non non mais un mec voile en ce moment
un mec en ce moment sur lequel vous
fantasmez n'a déjà sur ce j'ai fantasmé
sait déjà que j'ai déjà pas sec
donc oui qui pourrait y avoir 20 vous
sert il
ah oui ça démarre très bien cette année
ça avait mal démarré hier il m'a dit que
j'avais attention je n'ai même pas qui
c'était
voilà non mais vraiment mais ça me fait
plaisir ça me fait plaisir ne croyez pas
alors j'aimerais j'aimerais m'adresser
un autre à notre sexologue
alors dites-nous pourquoi pourquoi
kaoutar pourquoi elle est attirée vous à
votre avis pas parler beaucoup plus
jeunes comme ça en moi je peux dire en
règle générale en règle générale c'est
une manière d'associer deux formes
d'amour l'amour maternel et l'amour
érotique c'est à dire être à la fois
mère est à la fois maîtresse mer dans le
sens où souvent ces jeunes hommes elles
les éduque sexuellement mais elle leur
apprend à s'habiller à se tenir en
société et c'est souvent ce sont des
femmes accomplies qu'on plus rien à
prouver à personne et c'est manière
d'associer ses deux amours à la fois
maternelle est à la fois même si c'est
une maman poule
c'est son fils donc il ya un interdit
qu'il faut ça qu'il faut pas franchir
mais donc c'est aussi de manière
inconsciente de franchir aussi un
interdit quelques ici parce que nous
allons dire quelque chose le voyons vous
voyez quoi
non j'ai très admiratif en tous les cas
par rapport à votre parcours de vie et
mais ça ne s'arrêtera pas là bien
évidemment à et il peut y avoir des
discussions à l'heure actuelle par
rapport à un projet d'écriture de quoi
d'écriture de quoi gêner des pages
d'écriture
en fait j'adore mais je comprends rien
de qui
vous êtes sur un projet de libre oui
tout à fait non c'est quoi ce serait
quoi le livre une autobiographie
ouais ouais vous pour raconter comment
voilà ma petite fille jusqu'à maintenant
très bien alors alors on va vous faire
un petit jeu c'est très simple il y a
trois mascottes qui vont entrer trois
mascottes en fait donc vous n'allez pas
voir les personnes qui se trouvent dans
les déguisements
vous allez pouvoir on va leur poser des
questions les mascottes vont répondre et
vous choisirez la mascotte qui vous
semble le plus à votre goût il ya un
garçon très jeune il ya un garçon moins
jeunes il ya un garçon - - jeu d'accord
ok nicole oui il ya 27 40 et 70 ans
derrière ces mascottes attention on y va
a fait contrer et mascotte thomas leysen
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
première question
nicole heux franchement si on m'avait
dit que j'allais faire ça un jour mon
frère déjà la première émission est
folle on est comme ça là trois gars on
sait pas qui c'est et viennent en masse
comme mon frère il ya william hill et l'
iliden peu court on dirait qu'il a
glissé une barque à la tête et j'adore
ya un gage comprend m ce qui dit mes
cheveux qu'il ya du col qui va peut-être
me pécho notre déjà un enfant ça fait
quinze ans que j'ai pas ken non mais
attends mais sans alors les chéris
attention les mascottes donc je vous
posais des questions
nicole veut passer une soirée très
coquine avec vous qu'est ce que vous lui
proposez
on va démarrer par le lapin c'est un
lapin donc le lapin qu'est ce qu'ils
proposent avec le micro le lapin nique à
mon avis c'est lui donc
[Applaudissements]
l'émotion est grande nicole veut passer
une soirée très coquine avec vous que
lui proposez vous dans le micro merci
alors un restaurant qu'aucun merci nana
resteront donc tu crois que vous croyez
que ça peut se faire
d'accord ils ont déformé les bras pour
papa et moi fait les voies normales
parce que là on déjà qu'on voit pas le
gars sur un sol avec beaucoup dans une
seule séquence l'éléphant l'éléphant que
vous faites quoi pour une soirée coquine
l'éléphant avec le micro libertines
adorait dans une boîte libertines en
savourant des passes à liberty ricol
avait déjà été dans une boîte libertines
oui échangiste non non vous n'avez rien
n'est changé non d'être venu comme ça
oui dans une boîte
figurez-vous ciré que je suis allée en
discothèque que libertine mais
simplement pour juste parce qu il avait
deux amies qui avait besoin d'une fille
pour rentrer mais je m'en rappelle
j'étais là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas quel animal vous êtes un
loup saloum apparemment c'est un loup
voilà en tout cas bravo
et vous qu'est ce que vous lui proposez
une croix rouge avec des instruments une
chambre où j'avoue j'avais les
instruments là il ya un gars lui mais on
veut dire est qu'il est recherché par la
police
alors une chambre où les gars alors
deuxième question nicole veut faire
l'amour dans un lieu insolite quelle
gueule choisissez-vous le lapin quels
lieux choisissez vous le lapin je
choisirais soisy reste un lapin dans une
poêle une forêt de quoi une petite forêt
une forêt et perrier travail pourrait
vous avez déjà fait l'amour une forêt du
carrosse et là dans une forêt mais oui
vous avez déjà fait l'amour d'une forêt
bien sûr oui tout mon fils n'est pas
moins aigri là j'ai trouvé trop peur on
a fait des champignons
[Rires]
l'éléphant dans un ascenseur dans est
lui jeu que j'aime avec l'éléphant c'est
qu'à chaque fois qu'il a ce quelque
chose c'est le gars c'est un dépressif
dans un ascenseur le gars est un
éléphant déprécier dans un ascenseur
vous avez déjà fait dans un assaut non
we may et moi le livre ça va être sur un
guide les dernières pages sur les
bonnets quoi dans un ascenseur comment
s'est passé c'était quoi raconter
voudrais savoir ce qu'on a envie de sa
rapide
non mais quand ça s'est passé n'est pas
rapide valérie parce que en fait on
bloque vous avez bloqué l'ascenseur oui
comment s'est passée en fait s était
dans un ancien de travail dans un grand
bureau effectivement on a simulé
l'ascenseur en panne et on s'est accordé
dix petites minutes
oui c'est verdès et vous alors le loup
vous avez déjà vu le loup comme ça
nicole heureusement connaît et lui dit
la tour eiffel non mais toi depuis tout
à l'heure tu dis n'importe où l'on sait
pas qui tu es mais tu dis maintenant
alors nicole c'est comme ça à priori
vous choisiriez qui ya le lapin qui ne
l'a pas en valeureux définir c'est
quelqu'un c'est quelqu'un du terroir
c'est quelqu'un de bucolique
voilà c'est quelqu'un qui aime la nature
ensuite y'a l'éléphant lui
lui il a un truc à faire il le fait
voilà il ya du l'ascenseur voilà et il
ya le look est un petit peu le genre à
dire le le serial killer
mais les pillages
lui c'est plus on le retrouvera bientôt
dans three main sur une aire genou alors
vraiment serré je suis embêté je suis
très embêté r je sais pas qui choisir et
les probables en fait des progrès face
bas non non il y en a plus que l'autre
pendant 6 et sérieusement à votre avis
qui plus jeune dans ses propositions
parce qu'on rappelle les uns il ya une
personne de 70 ans sous la mascotte
ouais donc j'espère qu'on va vite la
libérer parce qu'on peut la perdre
il ya 27 ans et 40 ans donc alors à
votre avis qui est le plus jeune le
lapin l'éléphant ou le loup cette
question est bonne il faudra les autres
et bâle ou alors je dirais plutôt a le
plus souffert vraiment le plus jeune oui
mais plus jeune au plus vieux c'est qui
les louent que de loi le look plus
jeunes d'accord on va les classés du
plus jeune au plus vieux après match
tirer le lapin et ensuite les laisse
donc le plus vieux se serait l'éléphant
si vous pouvez vous êtes mercy mercy toi
il ya une personne donc d'une
quarantaine d'années eh bien eh bien
voilà c'est cette personne voilà merci
christian merci d'être là
[Applaudissements]
deux ans
vous attendez mais ce stock au bout du
rouleau il a une phrase mon frère on
dirait johnny après un concert à sa
récolte alors là vous pensez que vous
pensez donc elle est un peu plus âgé et
c'est romain qui à 27 ans marc roma roma
c'était la forêt l'invasion khroma vous
plaît bien
si on a laissé le plus âgé pour les deux
sont très bons les deux sont très bien
et enfin et bien l'éléphant avait 70 ans
puisque c'est notre ami c'est notre ami
venant
non non non non non c'est à 70 ans
oui c'est que je savais pas je sais que
tu sais pas mais je n'ai jamais dit bah
oui c'est vrai qu'un pas que moi qui
fais pas ça lui venant fesser études ans
comme un foot en plus est un tu peux tu
peux ne vous inquiet des mots comme ça
du coquelicot
voilà vous êtes complètement voilà en
tout cas merci des garçons d'avoir été
avec l'ouverture
voyez est donc en fait est bon on voit
donc c'est plus une question de physique
quand même parce qu'il faut vous les
voyez pour sentir canalisons est vrai
c'est plus une histoire de peluches ah
ouais c'est vrai adacore bon va très
bien valérie vous est ce que est ce
qu'ils avaient envie maintenant de
tenter peut-être l'expérience que nicole
nous a ramenés vers l vers les cougars
est évidemment je ne vais pas vous jeter
la pierre est ce que vous attendez
attendez il ya un rique qui m'appelle
free hamma dit omar que moi ça bug à
l'eau on en direct parce que je leur ai
dit de maples à 14h30 et pourquoi
vouloir pour les faire chier
alors les chéris non je comprends tout à
fait mais moi je suis vraiment attirés
par des décors plus plus mature ah ouais
à bien la balle avec ce que vous avez
avec la maison c'est très mature il est
pas non plus il a 52 ans
oui mais bon quand on voit son corps ils
ont fait 75 à balan récent rally le 10
août et ne seraient comme on l'appelle
nous avons la paix la marmelade
non mais à l'est de sanaa store on va
faire la connaissance de david qui est
juste qu et justin d'ailleurs c'est pas
david va faire la connaissance de xavier
dans un instant médias le grand jeu des
35 heures de baba plus de 20000 euros de
cadeaux à gagner pendant ses trente cinq
et ont déchiré des week-ends jours des
hôtels et des casinos des week-ends dans
un parc d'attraction des bons d'achat
relooking des smartphones pour
participer vous envoyer baba bab en tout
simplement par sms au 7 38 38 ou appeler
le 39 27 et vous répondez à la question
qui s'affiche sur votre écran la
question la voici quelques chroniques
heureuse de touche pas à mon poste et
aux côtés de cyril hanouna celle de deux
mois dans l'émission touche pas à mon
après midi est ce que c'est valérie
bénaïm ou est ce que c'est vrai qu'on
les confond souvent isabelle morini bosc
à vous de dire à ou deux voilà et vous
gagnerez un magnifique cadeau en tout
cas merci nicole
je fais je ferai un petit blouson nicole
je resterai 35 heures avec va on va déjà
faire 35 secondes ce sera mon record
williams oui dans mon lien mais très
bien question vous pensez du dd des
looks un poteau de la table avant de
passer à xavier à huy copenhague vous
avez sur nous comme ça avec le blues aux
maladies et des biens tout à abira
sushiman sushiman directeur des sushis
derrière vous avez même chose c'est le
seul truc qu'on voit pas mal mais c'est
bien dommage de pas les voir ni rien n'a
changé chez dell non là on est très bien
comme ça
changer de lunettes vous arrive un drame
une dent
j'ai perdu dans mes mains sur la tête de
ma mère voilà les 35 heures des bas et
j'ai perdu donc
c'est beau
jamais été que j'appelle le dentiste en
direct non mais sans déconner j'appelle
au christ en direct et on apprendra le
docteur who paquet là on peut appeler le
docteur attendez on va appeler docteur
[Musique]
oui
gfr est ce que c'est possible dans cette
chaîne j'ai demandé à docteur on dira si
rory le nom mais sur la tête de ma mère
on dirait qu'il va et on dirait qu'il va
exploser une forte
non mais et c'est le seul docteur et
bien ce truc sans malaise en n1 comme ça
tout est là bas derrière vétustes eu
crois qu à weight artistes et tout ce
que vous allez voir karim docteur karin
oui vous aurez un merci d'être là
qu'arrive j'ai perdu un morceau de dent
c'était une provisoire
ouais bon toi tu peux rien faire n'est
pas dans six ans malheureusement et ben
alors tu vas faire des études que tu
reviendras c'est tout non mais comment
je fais karim il faut que j'appelle le
dentiste sans déconner il faut que
j'appelle le dandy je vais appeler tout
de suite karim mais comment tu me sens
là bien la boîte à quelque chose pour
moi au cas où ouais ouais ouais c'est
des cachets des cachets il était à te
fais de l'apathie je te dis que j'ai pas
du tout confiance en toi
et bien la personne c'est ce docteur qui
va vous suivre ses bouquets les maires
n'ont pas trente cinq heures non non en
effet selon ses médecins
on peut pas là mais karim tu as quoi là
dedans ça c'est pour quand il a un truc
pour se laver les mains
c'est le seul hôtel à booster mais non
mais ça il paraît que tu as un
réanimateur et tout là bas
oui parce que je fais à la base suis
anesthésiste réanimateur donc les dents
je sais pas de quoi tu voulais
manifester pour faire des 35 heures
karim en tout cas moi je t'aime bien
géré je n'aurai pas de problème c'est
tout ce que j'espère mais je te sens tu
restes avec moi tu es là au cas où il ya
un truc tu interviens direct direct soit
pour le shérif ce pôle est dans mon
match a fait de l'anti
je garde fait tout de suite j'ai appelé
tout de suite quand même un nani qui est
dentiste non mais je vous jure que c'est
vrai non mais peut mettre une provision
à regarder j'ai perdu une dent sans
déconner on dirait on dirait un requin
dans quelques secondes
non je peux pas sourire donc vous pétez
doit quand même
mais oui un ça va allô allô
voilà ça va pas je t'appelle je suis en
direct la comaga justement haut parleurs
dit moi je suis dans la merde parce que
je suis à l'antenne là pour les 35
heures j'ai perdu ma dent may provisoire
non mais sans rigoler je crois qu'un
moyen moyen de saccager le morceau de
dent ouais tu peux pas vous voyez là
même celle m suite
c'est vrai tu nous rappelles on est en
direct on attendait sur le quai ville
reprendra le 6
on va avancer bon ben voilà bon bah on
va enchaîner avec xavier qui est avec
nous bougeons clavier mais rata merci
alors je vous le rappelle si vous ne
c'est une émission une émission de
témoignage aujourd'hui parce qu'on en a
toujours rêvé de faire ça valérie benaïm
et moi donc on s'y retrouver avec des
gens voilà qui vont témoigner ça va les
gars on voit aussi un tout va bien ça va
alors xavier on s'intéresse à vous vous
êtes vous êtes en fait quoi dans la vie
je cherche du travail dans quoi pour
l'instant je dois reforme en développeur
web développeur web
voilà tu aimes bien surfer sur le net
exactement un manga vous venez d'où tu
viens d'où oui on est à 30 ans à devant
des vendéens mais j'aime bien en tout si
c'est ma ville préférée
damien nantes où dois je suis nantais
dans le coeur et est vendéen niveau de
l'habitation quoi d'accord mais d'accord
battue et été votée moi j'aime bien
alors pourquoi tu nous a contacté xavier
des gens se rencontrent et talent les
rues et c'est vrai que tous les dons ne
vient d'accrocher ouais on s'est bien
entendu on s'est embrassé ou alors on
sait bien aimé c'est vraiment pas mon
clavier
oui très bien voilà très bien si tu
penses le contrat tu n'hésites pas le
dire je préfères tu dise des choses
alors pourquoi pourquoi tu nous a
contactés pour participer à cette
émission parce qu'il y avait une rue en
fin de mandat de témoignages pour 30 ans
toujours puceau saliver l'accord ouais
donc alors tu as ta jamais connu l'amour
voilà pourquoi c'est toi tu est timide
attempto ce palais vers l'est vers l'est
vers les chinois sur un peu timide mais
bon pas puisque ça c'est plus que ça va
je n'étais pas tomber encore sur la
bonne perdante a déjà eu des rendez-vous
à aider avec des meufs tout ça non pas
vraiment non pas vraiment sur internet a
déjà créé sur internet mais bon après
t'as pas envie de les voir en fait on se
voit ça c'est que j'ai pas de réponse
après moi c'est vrai sur internet c'est
pas vraiment le meilleur l'endroit je
pense au fait tu aurais si tu crois
avoir joué
non mais franchement je voudrais un avis
de la la la le psychologue et sexologue
sur internet ce qu'on peut faire des
rencontres qui peuvent durer
ah oui oui tout un service de ses
clients alison lohman arrive c'est un
lieu comme un autre on y trouve toutes
formes de personnes est la cible
xavier est ce que parce que tu as
répondu tout de suite un très bon t'as
envie d'en parler peut-être pour eux
pour voilà pour pouvoir avancer ensuite
pour pouvoir un peu défi qu'il voit
comme dans l'amour est dans le pré où il
ya des jeunes
voilà qui voit d'agriculteurs pour
envoyer des lettres des sms des tweets à
davie a et xavier et polo voilà non mais
donc voilà pourquoi ne voulant pas ta
gueule tu fais gaffe je te dis fait la
france mais pourquoi tu voulais en
parler c'est vrai que ce n'est pas parce
que je passe à enfin c'est plus facile
d'en parler comme ça c'est que la télé
quoi ouais je connais pas voulait des
conseils c'est ça aussi oui un peu oui
puis bon pourquoi qu'est ce qu'est ce
qui bloque en fait c'est qu'une fois que
tu arrive devant la la jeune fille qui
était un peu bloquée tu sais pas trop
comment faire un jouet un petit peu un
simple on habite tout seul ou pas l'âge
habituel mes parents sont comme moi tic
mois 30 ans j'habitais chez mais pas
encore c'est le jour donc je te lis donc
on a déjà un point commun est et on me
dit qu'on me dit que dans le public
théâtre est venu avec une amie qui
s'appelle sabine oui sabrina est
derrière elle et elle est aussi bine sûr
si longue
parce que sabine qui est dans le public
ça fait combien de temps que vous êtes
copine avec xavier sabine un an et demi
un an et demi alors au départ est ce qu
il voulait avoir une aventure avec vous
bien toute ma vie si tu n'es pas tout ça
s'est fait attendre quelque chose quand
il a senti un peu après tu vois ta vie
bat a tenté mais après il ya rien après
y'a rien du bed bath qui doivent aider
courtois et ils accès très il il a
essayé pourquoi ça s'est pas fait en
fait j'adore le micro on s'est rencontré
en soirée et tout et après c'était par
sms pas d'accord voilà et donc que vous
êtes resté copains oui très beau très
très bon l'instant peut-être que ça peut
déboucher sur de l'amour je pense pas tu
es ton choix c'est ton choix franchement
c'est ton choix oui valérie question est
est-ce que vous sortez mais partant
puisque vous avez une copine à ce qu
effectivement avec cet ami vous ne
sortez au restaurant dans des soirées
justement voir d'autres personnes et
élargir votre cercle de connaissances
bas à nantes où beaucoup mais là je suis
plus chez en vendée - mais sinon je suis
assez régulièrement et des amis au web
et quand vous êtes conviés à des jeunes
filles qui vous place vous osez les
aborder non non c'est compliqué
d'affronter plus compliqué dans la rue
par exemple ou dans une soirée si je
vois quelqu'un pourrait me plaire fifa
après voilà ces congés j'ose pas aller
ouais c'est compliqué en fait qu'est-ce
qui vous blacks
je sais pas peut-être la peur du refus
on a bien assez ça et après je suis un
peu timide aussi non alors si je peux
donner un petit conseil la peur du refus
je les ai connus
non mais vraiment il faut tenter voilà
après faut rester courtois voilà si la
fille jeune fille dit non c'est non
mais vaut toujours mieux rentrer chez
soi en ayant tenté quelque chose qu'en
dix ans j'aurais dû j'avais une brèche à
un moment dans la voiture j'amène bref
j'avais un truc non il faut que tu
tombes
voilà un franchement non mais c'est vrai
en plus xavier si je peux me permettre
je te jure que c'est vrai je ne rigole
pas été extrêmement sympathique moi je
t'ai vu en loge normalement franchement
tu dois trouver une meuf 1 mais je te
lire non mais je te dit et sympathique
franchement tu es sur twitter question
d'été sur des réseaux sociaux tout
arrive à parler à des meufs à mon avis
tu n'arrives pas sauter le sait le
dernier pas en fait je crois que c'est
ça qu'est ce que qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
vous pourquoi pourquoi c'est ça le bloc
comme ça le dernier dernier passage le
dernier passage ça il a peur
effectivement du refus et puis bon mais
tranquille souvent c'est parce que il ya
il ya un manque de femmes ont confiance
de confiance mais savoir faire aussi
c'est à dire qu'il ya toute une
éducation autour de 2 du fait de pouvoir
discuter être à l'aise avec l'autre
comment aborder l'autre qui s'est
certainement pas fait peut-être
peut-être quantité copains et et
expérimenté tout ça peut-être que l'ue
était un peu plus en retrait peut-être
que voilà il ya beaucoup de pistes 1
claude est ce que vous avez ce que vous
voyez quelque chose que vous avez vu
donc nicole allait créer un livre est ce
que xavier va connaître l'amour ou pas
quand vous le sentez vous notre voiture
que les gens bien sûr qu'il va connaître
l'amour mais comme ça parce qu'on a
besoin d'avoir des data
[Rires]
il peut cacher des cas xavier venez
venez il va plus chez descartes un
vannier là parce qu'on va voir
il ya un autre volet entier là mais on
en faisait on a besoin de savoir un
manga vous appelez vous aviez regarde
pas des yeux magnifiques j'avais même
pas vu que tu avais mais tu as les yeux
vers les yeux bleus ou verts bleus ne
l'a peut être pas trop quand même
alors à combler de prendre le car fait
aller à mon jeu cette carte là on est
dans la merde
ce que je propose c'est que en ce qu'on
va faire c'est que claude va faire il va
faire pocher les sept cartes à xavier on
va se retrouver dans un instant il y a
également notre coach en séduction qui
est là qui va donner des conseils à
xavier regarder ça c'est beau ça s'est
passé
photo avec votre témoignage
si m
[Musique]
on est en direct on est en direct et on
va faire 35 heures d'antenne les photos
intimes états astag les hashtags 30 35
heures de ba ba voila quand s'inquiète
baba ils me disent des trucs là voilà
dans des des hashtags on rigolait
incompréhensible fait hashtag 35 heures
de baba ça suffira largement voilà merci
les shihri alors les chéris on va être
ensemble encore bas comme on l'appelle
avec plein témoignage là si vous nous
rejoignez ben vous avez fait la
connaissance vous êtes fait la
connaissance de nicole voilà qui est
miss cougar la 57 ans allait magnifique
vraiment que cette magnifique nicolas et
je vous le dis franchement vous êtes
très très belle et elle aime la vie lm
qui fait voilà nicole c'est quoi votre
prochaine sortie la sortie ce week end
[Musique]
mais pourquoi je ris vous sentez plus
que jamais
en clair qu'on n'a rien à voir avec les
discothèques dans une des quelque chose
de bon coup qu'ils savent de quoi je
vais je vais faire les vendanges et jeu
et comme je fais partie d'une confrérie
voyons je vais faire une cérémonie dans
ma confrérie d'accord mais là bas c'est
une très bonne nouvelle
on voit quelqu'un voulait oui il donnait
veulent et moi je venais call d'accord
volusia bord qu'elle avait dû comme un
petit peu la personne qui a un grand jeu
vous le savez puisqu'il y aura beaucoup
beaucoup de cadeaux gagnés pendant ses
trente cinq heures plus de 20000 euros
de cadeaux à gagner des séjours pour 4
personnes oui c'est pas une c'est pas de
vous partez pas seul comme des chiens il
ya d'autres chaînes il vous dira voilà
il ya un séjour pour une personne et tu
pars tu te retrouves au bout du monde
comme un schiergen quoi nous vous êtes
quatre boîtes à trois potes avec toi tu
kiffes à même d ennemis tu peux amener
tu veux tu amènes qui tu veux un des
vacances au ski des vacances au soleil
des week-ends dans des hôtels et des
casinos il ya des maîtres des week-ends
dans des casinos un carrément cd ya des
gars on les met dans des casinos ils
bougent pas pendant un week-end le
gardien jetons revient de 48 heures
après il faut qu'ils aient toujours le
jetons mais je vous le dit voilà il ya
des week ends à parc d'attractions ya
des bons d'achat ronald king est
important d e.on relookera quelqu'un
tout à l'heure il ya des smartphones
alors pour participer vous envoyer baba
donc baba comme son nom l'indiqué bab à
par sms ou 7 38 38 vous appelez le 39 27
et vous répondez à la question qui
s'affiche ici au bas de votre écran et
sans rigoler quand je fais ça je le sais
j'ai l'impression vraiment d'être way sa
salle en salle ancienne menacé en haut à
gauche et non à ses parts à quoi voilà
qu'elle chroniqueuse de touche pas à mon
poste eto'o est à mes côtés
donc dans l'émission touche pas mon
après midi 1 valérie bénaïm de isabelle
morini-bosc ou bien quoi
bien valérie benaïm pas maquillée merci
si vous nous rejoignez seulement
maintenant nous étions avec xavier
xavier il a 30 ans il cherche un travail
en formation développeurs dans le web
etc ça si je te fais chier
moi je sais tout faire pour toi depuis
le début j'essaie d'être là j'essaie
d'être ta béquilles j'essaie d'être le
gars voilà qui qui qui te soutient dans
toutes les situations et taiwan dit
qu'il a des yeux magnifiques tu dis son
bleu ou vert ils sont bleus et verts
connard ça va ça bah moi aussi j'ai mes
soucis
cc nous rejoignent et sachez que j'ai
perdu une dent voilà ah oui on attend
des nouvelles du dentiste il m'a dit je
te rappelle emma apparemment il était il
était sur un doigt sur un dossard mon
avis voilà enfin vous connaissez les
dentistes alors xavier donc vous n'avez
jamais connu l'amour à 30 ans vous
habitait toujours chez vos parents et
vous avez décidé de venir nous voir pour
un petit peu pour briser la glace
on va pas se mentir ouais ouais bah vous
êtes venu avec votre meilleure amie quai
derrière avec qui vous avez tenté
quelque chose mais ça c'est pas fait
pour des raisons qui lui incombent
c'est ça la vie c'est ça vous n'êtes
plus du tout amoureux d'elle non non non
non j'ai tenté ça c'est pas fait coûte
c'est une amie voilà battant bien et la
mitis est important qu'ils aient
beaucoup d'amis d'amis femme ou pas
ouais quelques-unes combien à 4,5 et
vous avez tenté avec tout bas ben on en
a qui sont moins chers
[Applaudissements]
damien frérot j'essaie de te remonter
j'essaie de te faire pécho tune sort des
phrases comme ça après tu vas connaître
dans le mur au rival et je fais tout
pour me balader
c'est toutes les femmes sont belles et
wayne être franc il parle trop cachot
fille non mais j'aime bien ça jamais
enfin on peut pas dire à une fille tu es
trop moche non c'est pas le meilleur
démarrage non là n'est pas le meilleur
anglais revenaient du mystère après ça
peut décoder nommé siret et cash comme
ça toi examen il peut cette fois là je
vois le levier
je suis comme avant avant qu'on parte en
pause il ya est un monsieur alexis dont
claude alexis ses deux prénoms j'ai
remarqué comme souvent tous les voyants
c'est vrai et puis les coiffeurs jean
louis david élan à un poil jean louis
david guetta bien foutu dans la gueule à
la mode
il a tiré donc cette carte un pour la
voyance et donc qu'est-ce que ça dit est
ce que xavier va connaître l'amour
prochainement si oui on aimerait savoir
si c'est dans les dix prochaines années
parce que le gars est pressé est ce que
tu as des dossiers en cours ou pas ou
pas du tout pour l'instant pas rien mais
nadal a battu que tu me donnes ça peut
ça peut jouer ça peut jouer à
l'international claude moi j'ai annoncé
à xavier qu'il allait faire une
rencontre alors si on en fait
[Rires]
parce qu'il ya des gars qui n'ont
rejoint d'après-midi ils sont pas encore
dans le délire
sachez qu'on est en direct et moi
j'adore claude et on le prend comme ça
c'est sa voix oui il il est tombé dans
un ballon d'hélium étant jeune oui voilà
on aime bien claude bouchery alors donc
donc il va rencontrer quelqu'un sur le
crâne avec un z
tu n'étais pas dans le dos quand alors
oui dans 2017 et une personne un petit
peu plus âgés que lui non
[Rires]
est-ce que alors est-ce que déjà exavier
ce te dérange de sortir avec quelqu'un
de plus âgé que toi je vais combien va
vendre quelques années par exemple
nicole c'est une belle femme oui oui je
pourrais nicolle pourrait être intéressé
non je suis pas trop pour l'instant
diplômé je peux me permettre examen j'ai
des patrons j'ai pas dis je trouve
xavier délatté timide parce que je sens
que tu aimes bien nicole métaux ce pas
le dire ne fait pas du discours de l'iss
non alors donc 2010 est il pas connaître
quelqu'un de plus âgé un peu plus âgés
entre 2 et 3 ans dont trois en bas ça va
bah non plus un ça va et donc ça va se
faire oui mais il faut qu'ils s'ouvrent
un peu plus vers l'extérieur c'est ça
ces armes sont tous plus ta porte
fenêtres et portes ouvertes où tu
laisses les jeunes rentrée puis terminer
vos études vous tient au courant quand
même xavier alors avant parce qu'on veut
vraiment et toutes les cartes en main
quand va se présenter
l'occasion ce que l'occasion fera larmes
je passe je connais expression donc on a
pour toi quelqu'un qui est venu
expressément un et c'est un coach en
séduction c'est david qui est à côté de
toi
david il a 38 ans et si vous êtes avec
nous sur ces huit en direct si vous
aussi vous avez des problèmes pour voilà
pour conclure et bien il va nous donner
les clés un david david déjà c'est votre
métier fait que ça vous êtes coach en
séduction
ouais c'est à dire toute la journée il
ya des mecs qui vous d'appel où je suis
aimerait plus chaud marquina mais j'irai
donc et moi ça se passe vous allez voir
les gars chez eux ou fait des exercices
je fais des jeux fait des formations en
ligne et je fais des coachings live en
fait à des coûts directement dans la rue
ou en boîte mais vous vous êtes un grand
dragueur saviez vous avez toujours été
un grand dragon non en fait moi avant
j'étais extrêmement timide en fait ça
c'est ça j'étais bloqué j'étais
complètement paralysé tête dans deux ans
tu es coach en séduction donc bien en
tête tu es là tu me dit vas-y années que
tu fous là
roche et ewen j'étais vraiment paralysé
jeu en plus j'ai fait des comment j'ai
fait si tu technique
il y avait une fille pour 30 élèves dans
la classe donc on était à 30 francs net
à 1 29 dessus donc est un peu compliquée
et pendant mes études
voilà c'est au niveau de la concurrence
et des modèles pas évident voilà donc
pendant longtemps je fais étudiants qui
étaient il ya papa il pas une nana et
après quand je suis
sortie d'école après je pars et franche
d'un milieu technique puis avait que des
mecs et j'étais pas du tout je savais
pas du tout comment aborder une fille
bien à l'époque je n'avais pas dans les
amis de mes amis donc forcément fait que
je trouve une solution parce que et il
n'y avait rien à quoi
et pourtant me disait que j'étais super
gt bien super bien quoi voilà un bon
résumé ça a été le déclic
le déclic c'est que je me suis dit bas
au lieu des hauts lieux d'études et des
bouquins de maths physique peuvent
étudier un peu là comme le développement
personnel une confiance en soi
enfin j'ai commencé comme ça j'ai partie
par les bouquins parce que moi j'avais
que ça enfin je savais faire que ça
enfin voila j'ai le même problème
voilà donc j'ai commencé par les livres
et après voilà j'ai commencé à essayer
d'aborder des filles dans la rue tout
cela forme de faire relâche donc vous
êtes pris beaucoup de gestes oui
beaucoup de vent oui j'ai bah oui j'ai
pris beaucoup de boue énormément de vent
énormément de rejet mais je me suis dit
non faut pas je reste comme ça quoi je
peux pas je voyais je vois tout le monde
autour de moi et j'avais le même
physique ou pas avant parce que là vous
êtes comme il est beau gosse quand même
on voit qu'il a travaillé son physique
j'avais des petites lunettes et j'étais
moi je travaillais aussi un peu sur le
physique c'est ça je suis pas non plus
hyper beau gosse l'âge et des lumignons
valérie filet mignon maintenant il est
bon c'est inquiétant mais nicole ah oui
tout à fait nicole elle est surtout les
deux semaines
après j'ai bossé sur tout tout ce qui
pouvait m'aider en fait à ce que ça
marche en fait donc d'accord oui compris
physique mais tout ce qui était possible
en fait pour m'en sortir parce que j'en
avais marre quoi valérie mais ça veut
dire que vous ou que vous vous imaginez
qu'il ya une techno follistes que vous
imaginez pas une technique pour draguer
les filles et que c'est la même
technique pour toutes les filles et que
ça fonctionne forcément c'est que
mathématique non j'ai pas dit qu'il y
avait une technique pour toutes les
filles j'ai dit que en fait moi je n'ai
pas de solution donc en fait il fallait
que je trouve une solution
donc en fait moi j'étais prêt à prendre
j'étais prêt à prendre n'importe quoi ah
ouais donc eh oui une technique pour
commencer quelque chose mais il faut
bien démarrer par quelque chose donc oui
j'ai cherché des techniques parce que
j'avais rien versement via des systèmes
permettent gilles m'a dit qu'il y avait
une technique pour tous un peu net ou le
conseil que vous donneriez à xavier je
crois c'est aussi il faut qu'ils
commencent
c'est ça c'est un petit grand salan non
mais c'est ça non comme le ski oui il
est pas tout de suite chamois d'or qui
commence mais en fait ce qui est dur au
début en fait c'est d'abord dit croire
en fait ouais d'y croire quand ça fait
des années qu'ils se passe rien quand on
a rien en fait la première premier truc
c'est le premier challenge en fait quand
on part de zéro c'est de se dire si je
suis capable
si j'ai confiance en moi je vais trouver
et de se dire que il y a quelqu'un pour
moi ce qui m'attend quelque part je sais
pas et la question c'est mal servis
comment il devait faire vrai qu'elle
soit en vendée parce qu'il va pas faire
le tour du monde mauvais mais un peu
importe parce que l'idée c'est de se
dire je ne sais pas comment mais je sais
au moins qu'elle existe au moins être
sûr que cette personne existe parce que
là on se dit plus que on doit trouver
une technique on sait que la personne
existe on sait qu'on est capables de la
trouver il faut juste trouver qui est
cette personne qu elle voulait dire
quelque chose là dessus
oui si je peux me permettre d'accorder
vous il y à des techniques bien sûr au
départ bon voilà on part sur des choses
ni à une personnalité et la confiance en
soi la confiance en soi on n'a peut-être
pas forcément la trouver comme ça tout
de suite a cherché à l'est on y va il ya
peut-être des thèmes techniques
je suis avec ça non non non mais je suis
d'accord en même temps je suis d'accord
david la seule chose c'est ce qu'il faut
pas déjà au départ se retrouver soi-même
avoir une confiance en soi d'abord soi
même peut-être un coaching beaucoup plus
la séduction est plus en confiance en
soi quand il ya développement personnes
arriver à séduire quelqu'un survient en
avant la vie exavier est ce que est ce
que ça te fait du bien déjà d'être avec
moscou moi je te dis la vérité
franchement je trouve très sympathique
je serai une meuf non bonjour je suis
persuadé que tu peux trouver une meuf
non mais je t'aurais dit si c'était mort
je te relèves 0 laisse tomber mais je
suis sûr c'est sympathique et souriant
huit mois par exemple il est venu me
voir dans la loge tout à l'heure où il
va il m'a pechoux la confiance
finalement sur lui il l'a élevée dans
une démarche de séduction était dans une
démarche 2 je viens de rencontrer
quelqu'un de jeu que j'ai vu à la télé
j'ai envie de lui parler
s'il applique à une jeune fille qui lui
plaît et avec qui il a envie d'aller
éventuellement plus loin parce qu'il n'y
avait pas d'enjeu pour lui de venir me
voir et me parler si quand tu rencontres
une jeune femme n'y a pas d'enjeu parce
que c'est pas grave si éventuellement il
dit non eh ben ce moment là ça ira
peut-être un petit peu mieux
j'ai 30 ans j'ai l'impression qu'il en
résulte au bout tu te fais chier et déjà
williams au niveau look
qu'est ce qui pourrait faire vis-à-vis
déjà pour montrer qu'il est plus sûr de
lui pour voir les choses un peu plus
structuré déjà comme ça tu pourrais
soutenir un peu plus d'aura c'est bien
quand tu va aborder quelqu'un c'est
important après si l'accord est alors
moi ce que je propose
xavier c'est que on tord au look avec
william vous partiez tous les deux on va
relooker xavier parce que moi je vais
dire ça vient et je te tutoie parce
qu'on est on à ses proches
on s'est parlé
on a fait une photo ensemble je crois
j'ai ton numéro 6 elle depuis tout à
l'heure il est puceau et n'en sais rien
peut-être ah oui et oui on dit elle
ll depuis tout à l'heure we dance est
vrai que tu peux être complètement open
tu sais ici sont complètement ouvert
nous aimons les voiles nous aimons les
vapeurs